If I could just nail the declension
tables, I'd be able to speak.
Didn't turn out to be the case.
Today, I want to talk about grammar
and why we shouldn't focus on
grammar in our language learning.
I've mentioned Manfred Spitzer
before, a German neuroscientist.
I enjoy listening to him.
It's good for my German and he
has many interesting insights.
I was listening to an audio book
called Dein Gehirn bist du, talks about
the brain, how you are your brain.
You can't get a brain implant
without becoming a different person.
And he says, I'm That the brain
is very good at creating patterns,
at recognizing patterns, not
very good at remembering details.
That's why we quickly forget the name
of someone who we're just introduced to.
However, the bigger picture, the
how things relate to each other,
uh, the broader Sort of sense of
a network of patterns is what the
brain is designed to create for us
so that we can get through our lives.
And he mentions a case of German,
German verbs that have ihren, like
spazieren, like to go for a walk,
or rasieren, you know, to shave.
They do not use the ge
before the past participle.
And if you get a group of Adults
or even children and present them
with non verbs that have even in it.
They will automatically not use
the prefix ge, whereas most past
participles in German, ge gessen,
ge lassen or ge lesen or whatever.
They take a gay as a prefix
to the past participle.
So in other words, children
have already absorbed this rule.
No adult knows this rule.
I found this very interesting video
about German verbs, 19 minutes
long, goes into a lot of detail
rules that I was not aware of.
But actually I use
German mostly correctly.
No one has ever corrected me.
I've just accumulated enough experience
through the massive exposure,
listening and reading in German,
that I mostly use it correctly.
And I remember when I was working
on a German ship and, uh, the German
crew, of course, I was trying to
somehow communicate with them.
And then my major learning activity
was studying declension tables.
I thought that was the key to German.
If I could just nail the declension
tables, I'd be able to speak.
Didn't turn out to be the case.
In English, children are able
to use articles, a, an, the.
There are some children who struggle,
but overwhelmingly kids know that
long before they have the benefit of
any grammar instruction, on the other
hand, speakers of languages where
there are no articles, despite lots
of grammar instruction, struggle.
To use articles because it's
not what they're used to.
They haven't enough experience with
English to use the articles correctly.
So when I read things like, if we
don't have grammar instruction,
we won't be able to speak.
I mean, all languages existed long
before anyone wrote down a grammar.
People develop these natural rules
of how to use the language by
some kind of a natural process.
They absorb these rules
from people around them.
The brain, as I said, as
Spitzer said, is very good.
So, we don't need specific grammar
instruction or we don't need
very much of it in any case.
So, that's point number one of
why we shouldn't focus on grammar.
Point number two is focusing on
grammar takes too much time away
from more useful activities.
We should be spending our time
Massively listening and reading and
eventually speaking, even with mistakes.
That's where our time should be spent.
But a lot of language
instruction focuses on grammar.
Here's this rule.
Here are some examples.
Now we're going to test you on it.
So a lot of time is devoted to grammar
and people are caught up in this
desire to ace these grammar rules.
Whereas they should simply be doing a
lot of listening and reading because
it takes a lot of time and the
more different the language is from
your own, the more time it takes.
And I'll show you my
statistics from LingQ.
You know, a language like Romanian,
even though the grammar is different
from other Latin or Romance languages,
so much of the vocabulary is similar.
And of course it's written in
the Latin alphabet that in a very
short period of time, I was able
to start conversing in Romanian.
I was able to do a lot of listening
and I moved along very quickly.
Whereas in Arabic or even in Persian,
which is an Indo European language, and
it's a lot easier than Arabic, it's hard
for me to get in a lot of meaningful.
Listening and reading in those languages
where the writing system is different.
There's not a lot of common vocabulary.
The structure is very different.
It's not the grammar that prevents me from
spending hours and hours of, you know,
enjoyable listening, meaningful listening.
It's my lack of words.
So the vocabulary buildup is the key
obstacle, not the fact that I don't
know the details of Arabic grammar.
So we need a lot of time to
listen and read and speak.
And we shouldn't be spending
that time on grammar instruction.
The third thing that I don't like
about a focus on grammar is that
inevitably grammar instruction
is connected with tests.
So it's an opportunity for the
teacher to teach something over
the book and then test you on it.
So immediately.
You have these tests, these
quizzes, you may get them right.
You may remember what you were just
taught and you might then forget
it again a little bit later on.
It's not contributing to a
gradual development of connections
and patterns in your brain.
But on the other hand, it's
creating a lot of tension.
around tests, it's introducing
the sense of failure.
It's introducing this idea that
you've got to try to nail things
down, which I don't believe is
very helpful in language learning.
Uh, you have to let the process
take its course, take the time
necessary to learn and not worry about
trying to nail down a grammar test.
So, that's the third thing.
The fourth thing, the reason why I'm
not a big fan of a focus on grammar
and getting people, you know, worried
about grammar is that it introduces what
Crashing calls the effective filter.
In other words, when you go to
use the language, now you're
trying to think of rules.
And in the case of German, I can assure
you that the rules for the formation
of the past participle of German verbs
is not the only thing in the language.
There are lots of rules.
And if every time you go to speak,
you got to try to think, is this
correct or is that correct, you have
to have the confidence that with
enough listening and reading, you
will get most of the things right.
And if you have most of the things
right, and if you have enough
vocabulary to do a lot of listening.
You will gradually develop
better and better habits.
And it's far better in my view to rely
on your habits and your instincts rather
than trying to remember specific rules.
The next reason why I'm not a big fan of
grammar instruction is inevitably grammar
instruction focuses on a limited range
of content, a limited variety of content.
We focus in on this rule and we have
examples of this rule, but every time you
look at the same information, the same.
example or the same rule, the brain
is working less and less hard.
This has been demonstrated
through magnetic imaging.
So you are actually
learning less and less.
You're far better off to be
encountering examples of usage patterns.
In a variety of different contexts,
in different books, in different audio
books, in different podcasts, in different
texts, you've got to spread that around.
You can't just focus in on limited
number of rules and examples and
expect that that is going to create
the necessary language competence.
It was interesting.
I was listening to a podcast this morning,
comparing artificial intelligence, like
chat GPT, to what happens in the brain.
And one of the major differences, and I
don't fully understand all this stuff,
but it seems to be that whereas, uh,
an AI model through massive millions
of hours of content or text will
be able to predict the next word.
Whereas the brain, because it's
engaged with a lot of, a variety of
different contexts, ends up being
able to predict beyond the next word,
seven or eight words further on.
The brain is engaged with
meaning, not just A word that has
appeared in different contexts.
So the greater the variety of context,
the broader our scope of ingesting the
language, the firmer we're going to be.
Grammar tends not to do that.
It tends to focus in on specific
rules and specific examples.
And finally.
I'm not saying you
shouldn't look at grammar.
I found that, uh, this 20 minute video,
and I would suggest you go, if you're
doing German, and there are videos on
everything for every language, different
aspects of grammar, it's interesting.
I'm not sure that the next time
I go to speak German, I want to
be thinking of these rules, but
it is a, some form of exposure.
It is interesting.
It's particularly beneficial
if you already have a lot of
experience with the language.
You've been exposed to a variety
of contexts through listening and
reading, and now you see a rule which
hopefully confirms something that you're
vaguely familiar with, or maybe have
been doing, or maybe it contributes
to you noticing certain things when
you listen and read, and gradually
improving your accuracy in the language.
We all want to be
accurate in the language.
It's not that we ignore correct usage.
It's just that in order to get to correct
usage, you actually need to spend a
lot of time listening, reading and
speaking and less time trying to focus
in on nailing down points of grammar.
And I'll leave you with a couple of
videos that I've done in the past on
this issue of vocabulary versus grammar.
And I very much believe that the
key to language learning success
is to have a large vocabulary and
therefore the ability to do lots of
listening and reading, enjoyable,
meaningful listening and reading.
And that will improve your accuracy
in speaking in the language.
Thank you for listening.